le plus rapidement le terroriste est
abattu et le mieux c'est pour tout le
monde alors on leur apprend toutes
sortes de techniques comment ils peuvent
fabriquer une arme avec une bouteille de
coca ou avec un journal ou alors comment
renverser un terroriste et toutes sortes
de façons de se
défendre pour ces Américains la guerre
chimique a déjà
commencé si vous sentez l'odeur vous
êtes
mortel' gaz mettez votre masque retenez
votre respiration enfilez votre
imperméable vérifie l'tanchéité souffle
pour faire sortir le gaz du masque et
commencer à respirer
normalement ce que vous venez de voir
c'est comment ajuster un masque à gaz
comment enfiler votre imperméable et
surtout comment bien vérifier que votre
masque marche et qu'il est étanche et
pourquoi tout ça à cause des attaques
chimiques qui vont se produire aux
États-Unis dans très peu de
tempsous dans banlieu de Miami ici comme
partout aux États-Unis on soutient les
troupes les boys engagés en Irak le
drapeau américain est partout dans les
rues on pavoise mais on a peur aussi
peur que la guerre chimique s'exporte
jusqu'ici alors tous ceux qui propose
des parades contre le terrorisme font
fortune dans cette armurerie on s'est
spécialisé dans la survie et depuis les
attentats du 11 septembre les affaires
marchent
bien
vous avez des provisions de nourriture
des produits pharmaceutiques ici un
générateur les portes leses sont isol
avec du plastique et du rub
adhésif toilettes port radio une
lampe gaz et des
armes il faut prévoir de pouvoir
survivre dans cet environnement pendant
une période de 7 à 10
jours dans la pièce d'à côté on propose
des cours de contreterrorisme pour 60 €
ces Américains vont pendant 4 heur tout
apprendre sur l'ennemi qui menace le
rêve
américain les terroristes détestent
l'Amérique pourquoi
dites-moi capitalisme quoi d'autre
liberté on a la liberté le capitalisme
on a des tokwis on a des téléviseurs
couleurs on est le meilleur pays du
monde on a la meilleure
armée et qu'est-ce qui pourrait mieux
alimenter leur rage que ce qui se passe
depuis 10 jours
avec les Américains en
IR si vous étiez iraien et que vous
viviez au USA aujourd'hui que
feriez-vous moi je me cacher et cachz
moi je fer du terrorisme Bonz disons que
ce soir on est des iraiens jeudi
prochain on va faire une sortie vous
vous allez me faire sauter un cinéma
vous un camion citne sur Disney World
vous des cocktail molot sur une
communauté Ju vous vous allez mitrailler
un commissariat de police et vous vous
allez poster 50 enveloppes avec une
poudre blanche à
l'intérieur est-ce que cela va se
reproduire en Amérique est-ce qu'on va
revoir ces images d'immeuble en feu aux
information comme pour le 11 septembre
je ne sais pas ce qu'ils attendent mais
je sens que ça ne va pas
tarder il y en a qui disent que je donne
ces cours de contterrorisme pour
effrayer les gens mais ce n pas
vrai cours pour leur apprendre à
survivre à un attentat
suicide ce soir ils vont apprendre à
tirer à survivre à une attaque à la
grenade à reconnaître un
terroriste à répondre à une attaque au
couteau tout cela peut leur sauver la
vie là vous pouvez voir les effets de
l'rax sur la
peau je train de travailler au bureau et
que quelqu'un tout le monde dehors il y
a de l'entrax dans le système
d'aircitionné bien je mets ça je mets du
scotchutour pour
les l'imuble est en feu l'immeuble est
en feu regardez ce que j'ai acheté pour
499 des lunettes de
natation de la chlorine du gaz moutard
nous tombbe dessus et qu'est-ce que j'ai
là un petit
imperméable
et voilà je peux me couvrir et cela va
me donner un sacré avantage par rapport
à vous qui n'avez
rien un avantage un vrai
avantage Angelo caparelli est ingénieur
depuis 10 ans il dirige une petite
entreprise d'assainissement en plein
Hollywood al-qaïa a menacé d'attaquer
les maternelles les écoles j'ai un neveu
et une nièce et je suis terrifié je n'ai
pas d'enfant mais si j'en avais j'aurais
très
peur ce que je fais pour moins angoisser
c'est d'essayer de m'instruire le plus
possible et d'essayer de comprendre
pourquoi Al-Qaïda déteste autant les
États-Unis pour soulager ses angoisses
Angelo a obtenu un port d'armes depuis
le 11 septembre il n'est jamais sorti de
chez lui sans son revolver il est caché
dans une petite pochette attachée à la
ceinture de son
pantalon le revolver est là dans cette
poche et je peux le sortir très vite
c'est une arme compacte bien pour ma
protection
elle contient 14
balles le 11 septembre 2001 c'était il y
a un an et demi et les gens ont tendance
à oublier je ne sais pas comment on peut
oublier ça mais on
l'oublie je que dans le futur la menace
terroriste va se
multiplier et devenir quotidienne et là
on ne l'oubliera pas on sera bien obligé
d'agir si quelqu'un crie
grenade vous plongez dans la direction
opp posé à la grenade remontez vos pieds
pourquoi parce que ça peut toujours vous
protéger un petit
peu vos coudes sur les côtés du corps
pourquoi parce que ça peut protéger vos
organes vitaux ok protégez votre visage
et vos oreilles quand la grenade
explosera vous survivrez
peut-être allez préparez-vous à plonger
à l'opposé de la grenade allez plonger
plonger plonger par
terre
bon qu'est-ce que vous faites maintenant
vous vous levez non vérifiez si vous
êtes blessé avez-vous mal êtes-vous
blessé bougez les pieds V pieds sont-ils
toujours
là demandez à votre femme est-ce que ça
va chéri ok c'est bien bon
boulot depuis 10 ans Hélène et Ervin
Becker profitent d'une retraite
tranquille dans cette résidence
bourgeoise de l'oderdel rien ne semble
mettre en danger leur sécurité pourtant
ils sont très
inquiets regardez il y a des pétroliers
qui passent des portes containers qui se
dirigent vers le port
et ce sont des cibles
potentielles nos vies ont bien changé
depuis le 11
septembre nous ne sommes plus
invulnérables bien au
contraire nous avions l'océan pour nous
protéger mais plus
maintenant depuis le début de la guerre
les B passent le vie devant leur po de
télévision au programme les chaînes
d'information américaine comme CNN ou
Fox News IRIN vousmême se lever la nuit
pour avoir des nouvelles du front
irakien
au bout d'une demiheure je retourne au
lit j'essaie de ne pas faire de bruit
mais je suis recouché j'entends ma femme
dire alors les
nouvelles et puis quand on se couche le
soir à 11h30 minuit la télé est toujours
allumée et si on sort le soir pour dîner
ou aller au cinéma on rallume la télé
dès notre
retour moi je vois un clash de
civilisation fondamentalistes musulmans
et le monde
occidental c'est la base de tout et
c'est ce qui m'inquiète le
plus je ne veux pas laisser la peur
changer mon mode de
vie ce sera une façon de se rendre à
l'ennemi mais quand vous voyez le nombre
de fondamentalistes dans ce pays prêt à
réapparaître au premier signal c'est
inquiétant
allez utilisez plus les mains regardez
vous voyez ce qui se passe là plus de
couteau boum
boum assurez-vous d'avoir une main
derrière le coude pour bien le prendre
pourquoi le coude regardez pour le
maîtriser c'est vrai que c'est court
comme démonstration mais ils
n'oublieront
pas s'ils se retrouve dans une mauvaise
situation je vous garantis qu'ils s'en
souviendront autre exercice comment
neutraliser un pirate de l'air irakien
bien
sûr je vous avais dit d'attendre de 30
secondes à une minute avant de lui
sauter dessus vous êtes un groupe un
tout petit peu trop
agressif ceci dit j'admire votre
bravo allez viens ici
toi agent de la sécurité aérienne tout
le monde se
baisse restez
baissé et voilà deux passagers descendus
parce qu'ils se sont pas
baissés le plus rapidement le terroriste
est abattu le mieux c'est pour tout le
monde alors on leur apprend toutes
sortes de techniques comment ils peuvent
fabriquer une arme avec une bouteille de
coca ou avec un journal ou alors comment
renverser un terroriste et toutes sortes
de façons de se
défendre
je ne crois pas qu'on puisse se sentir
complètement en
sécurité il faut juste essayer de
s'instruire le mieux
possible toutes ces informations ce soir
vont me permettre d'être un peu plus sûr
de
moi ça vous permet d'ouvrir les yeux sur
ce que vous devez faire dans certaines
situations si je peux apprendre à me
défendre je me sentira moins vulnérable
et si je me sens moins vulnérable ma
peur et mon anxiété
diminu
gaz gaz attaque au gaz attaque au
gaz le clou de la formation l'attaque
chimique nos étudiants ont 45 secondes
pour enfiler un masque à gaz et un
imperméable des articles qu'ils pourront
bien sûr acheter dans la boutique avant
de rentrer à la
maison